hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
salamander styling we're gonna check out
from nicole our boar dear fat people
Sally did mention that she saw some of
this video didn't finish it why'd you
stop me just start off by saying I'm not
a fan of her you'll hear my rant after
the video as to why did you turn it off
because of her I was pissed off yeah I
hated this video so what what is she a
comedian uh comedian quote-unquote
comedian well indeed Ian got my kitchen
here today your no this is hairspray or
semen dear fat people ah
so people are already really mad at this
video what are you gonna do fat people
what are you new wait what are you gonna
chase me really gonna chase me
it's gonna be like [ __ ] Frankenstein
I can get away from you by walking at a
reasonable pace Frankenstein not so fast
zombies have a barely gotten faster a
much like three episodes of The Walking
Dead and not being slow myself in the
brain realize that every single episode
is exactly the same
oh no they need something but it's all
the way over there where the zombies are
fat shaming is not a thing that people
made that up that's the race card with
no race yeah but I couldn't fit into a
store that's discrimination um no that
means you're too fat you should stop
eating and about you just need to make
boys that there's a race car is a
disability card there's even a gay car
because gay people are discriminated
against wrongfully so the gay card is
covered in glitter
it's [ __ ] magical are you gonna tell
the doctor that they're being need and
fat shaming you when they say you have
[ __ ] heart disease
I'm not talking about people who have a
little bit of cushion for the pushin it
was my disposition and health condition
this is not hey I got the 35 percent of
North Americans who are obese that means
you are so fat you are affecting your
own health big-boned isn't a thing how
stupid do I look
don't answer that they're no [ __ ]
stuffing is you feel like the Michelin
Man - Amy
who came up with that like yes shame
people who have bad habit I'm totally
[ __ ] stop bashing if we offend you so
much that you lose weight lose lose
weight I'm okay with that you are
killing yourself yeah I'll sleep at
night maybe I'm a little jealous that
you get to eat whatever you want
obesity is a disease yes I was being a
Shopaholic back that [ __ ] party bath
it would make a lot of sense if I did
I'm gonna lose all the bags fat people
parking spot should be at the back of
the wall parking lot walk to the doors
over some calories why are we helping
them wanna die quicker come this way
it's assisted suicide no ironic that is
taking a blonde girl to explain show its
irony right I don't you just that right
here cuz we're taking your body your
grandma if there were in fact Smarties
you're like you want [ __ ] this Marty you
smarty
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] mess you up I
didn't make you not good I'm a three on
the grader that's okay cuz you got a
bunch of other smarty you got one body
one it has to take you all the way to
the end you get that good [ __ ] you
smarty oh my god the hashtag spotty
positive if you want to be positive to
your body workout meat well that's being
positive to your body you really think
if enough of you hashtag something bad
for you it makes it okay hashtag mess
love I'll shag ding smoke up everybody
use the hashtag it'll unplug our
arteries they forgot to tell you that
plus-sized stands for a-plus heart
disease plus knee problems plus diabetes
plus your family and friends crying but
they lost you too soon because you
needed to have a coke plus fries Plus
that Plus that I was at the airport not
too long ago and I had to wait in one of
those lines it's like
as I get to the front of the line a
family comes to the front and gets to
bug me that is most obese I'm talking
TLC specials then you're in best shape
they got to go to the front of the line
cuz they were complaining that their
knees were too much to stand it oh I
just came an hour early like how it
supposed to but you overeat let me help
you and they complain and they smell
like sausages and I'm gonna get eight
sausages this is their aroma they were
so fat but they're that standing sweat
fat Krista was coming out of their pores
like a [ __ ] play-doh flush pretty
mean so I waited expecting 15-20 minutes
now I'm not gonna have time to get
Starbucks I'm like girl this is an issue
and I totally got felt up by security
because I'm always selecting brown
people it's me and you on that I'm a
blonde who can speak in full sentences
and there's no interest in your sugar
daddy I am a minority you already
searched my ass sir oh now I'm running
to my plane just as I stopped to wipe my
sweat who do I see in a [ __ ] golf
cart that family yeah so what you got to
bug me and ride in a golf cart and I'm
sweating like a pig but if I play an
ugly girl in the movie I get a [ __ ]
Oscar yeah yeah there's a formula to it
guess now I get on the plane I find my
lovely seat I'm sitting in the aisle and
then a stewardess walks up to me Jaime
and I hate to ask but we've got a
disabled passenger would you mind
switching seats of course cuz I'm not an
[ __ ] I'm like oh my god dude this why
look it's Fahrenheit announced and job
of the Sun sits right beside me I just
lost my [ __ ] his fat was on my lap it
was actually on my lap I took the yellow
they squished it downwards of my feet
yours
I actually took his fat and I pushed it
into a seat and I held it he was fine he
was just watching a movie no no no make
make better choices yes
genetics plays a part in things to a
degree of course it says if black women
and Trish dresses are my favorite thing
in the world selfish oh no idea the
correlation between high nuts and
calorie intake I'm not gonna question it
I'm not saying all this to be an [ __ ]
I'm saying this because your friends
should be saying it to you think of me
as one of your Ryder datas if you're
dating a douchebag and you come to me
all like my boyfriend's being a
douchebag that's because you're dating a
douchebag but what do we do get rid of
the douche ha ha true fact they used to
use vinegar as douches my lady bits just
reacted like a turtle's head being
touched the truth is I will actually
love you no matter what but I really
really hope this bond of truth exploding
into your face will act as shrapnel that
seeps into your soul makes you want to
be healthier so that we can enjoy you as
human beings longer on this planet
release mighty ouch tag-team smokers
thanks for watching everybody my name is
Nicole Arbour hey if you like this video
give it a thumbs up yeah subscribe right
there oh but other social links are
right below I hope you become a section
on this videos getting pretty funny feel
free to you that's why she disable the
comments yeah good she wasn't gotten a
lot of hate oh she must have got a lot
it's not like oh let's talk about the
issue of obesity let's just talk about
how [ __ ] popular I'm getting like on
her Twitter when everything got shut
down I saw a whole Twitter thing
happening her channel got shut down that
video got shut down everything people
were so happy about it but obviously
like she has freedom of speech I get
that so YouTube you know technically
didn't really have a right but it is
sort of like it can be categorized as
bullying like cyber bullying the fact
that she was talking about fat people
like that or obese people especially
children like that child
first of all diabetes does not come
because you are fat ok like there are
plenty my cousin has died
and she was really skinny when she got
diabetes and like having a disease like
that can actually cause you to gain
weight because of everything going on in
your body and everything changing and
having to really watch what you eat
just as you watch what you eat doesn't
mean you're not gonna get fat I don't
understand how she's thinking like oh if
you're just like exercise and eat right
you'll be fine and you should just do it
because it's it I'm suffering like I'm a
skinny white girl who can't get my
Starbucks and I'm suffering because
you're fat are you kidding me get the
[ __ ] off of YouTube
cuz you're the reason why I hate people
not every reason why he lied be boring
you - good isn't she just joking um you
would think that but I'm a cop I don't
call her a comedian you want to I don't
call her a comedian because she looks
like a washed-up Walmart version of
jenna Marbles and all she wants his
views and subscribers literally look at
her look at her Twitter all she cares
about is those numbers going up she
could not give a crap about her comedy
and how it might affect other people or
even writing like smarter comedy that
was not a smart comedy bit at all you
were just like talking [ __ ] first she
says fat shaming isn't a thing and then
she fat shames what the [ __ ] is that
and I'm doing did you make a good point
I mean looking at her videos uh like
dear Instagram models why you really got
divorces I feel like her brand of humor
is sticking to her own personal selfish
opinion and just really letting it out
on a video here's the thing if you're a
smart comedian there's a certain way you
have to go about things especially these
sort of topics and she's already pissed
a lot of people off even before this
like with the Instagram model thing
because she's such a hypocrite like if
you looked at her Instagram you know
what I mean and it's just kind of like
you can't talk about these things if you
don't know anything about them or if
you're doing them yourself it just
doesn't add up like she's not smart
about it I don't I mean I'm not negating
what you're seeing I'm not I'm not
saying you're wrong about what you're
saying I'm saying there's this other
side that I'm seeing or she's it seems
kind of smart it's so offensive it's so
talking [ __ ] I think that it has a
million four hundred thousand views now
marketing
is what you're not saying she's smart
well she's she knows what she's doing
like I don't think she's gonna get hurt
I don't see what its gonna get her in
the long run if like everyone [ __ ]
hates or like she's not gonna get
respect from respected people is what
I'm saying
you think so she wants to be like some
big youtuber like go ahead and do that
but you're not gonna have my subscribe
my subscription or a lot of other
people's subscriptions that really like
could get you somewhere if you really
wanted to be YouTube you don't go around
like talking [ __ ] and then like only
wanting to get subscribers just from
these big controversial topics or if you
really wanted to fix the issue you could
have gone about it in a different way
instead of being like oh here comment
let's talk about it and then disable the
comments your [ __ ] [ __ ] it's how much
you can say to make me think otherwise
yeah I don't want you to think otherwise
I just I don't I definitely don't hate
her the way you but there's parts of me
that kind of admire the darkness of what
she's doing that's that's just my little
YouTube satsang like imagine the kids
watching her videos that might have
weight issues feeling like [ __ ] after
watching that ya know I especially young
kids especially I call that young boy
like how she was so effective uses fat
was all over see like get a [ __ ] life
this is how frickin food disorders like
eating disorders happen that is how it
happens in young kids because it girls
like her you don't know how to shut the
[ __ ] up I feel like if someone develops
some type of disorder from watching this
video I feel like the video was only a
catalyst to a bunch of other [ __ ] that
really is the real cause of why they
developed it I understand that but she
wants people to really not be obese
so she's initially yeah yeah you know
what I mean like her whole message is
just totally distorted by the way she
came across that's why I have a problem
with it she's not a smart comedian if
that's the message she was truly trying
to get across it's not um witty comedy
it's more talking [ __ ] and then like
it's less cracking jokes it's more
trying to make points and then there's a
lot of hypocrite
yeah it's a talking [ __ ] about someone
and then being like oh by the way like
you know totally didn't want the best
for them that's exactly what she just
did yeah no I I think I think she's
totally aware
she's doing that's the one thing where
I'm like well at least she's aware what
she's doing and she's choosing to do
that not me I agree with her choices but
if this has such a big backlash like it
does like all those views are from
people that are really freaking pissed
off I feel like she had I mean like I
never say like oh don't apologize for
your comedy but that wasn't comedy that
was seriously just being mean and I'm
trying to write it off as comedy I think
she should apologize for that another
main reason why I got so upset was
because do you know grace Helbig on
YouTube no it's great she's one of the
biggest oh yeah universe I don't wanna
have a female comedians on YouTube right
now she posted a video about how upset
she was with this video because she's
only had like two serious videos on her
wife all of her stuff is comedy and she
actually posted a video where she almost
cried because this woman triggered
something in her that caused her to talk
about it if this girl triggered one of
the biggest successful comedian
youtubers on the internet right now what
makes you think like she hasn't
triggered a lot of young kids that have
eating disorders or have other issues
with themselves you are persuasive you
are persuasive she gets herself
attention and our way she's smart but I
have no respect for you oh she has a
video [ __ ] Claus sounds interesting
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out salamander Sally's
channel where it's about making
hard-hitting point of views about
society certain influences in the nagas
it's it's really about going after the
man at the end of the day really
powerful messages there and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine periscope and let's do shout out to
um now towers
but discharged you say that like it was
a real man hey guys can I get a shout
out I really love your videos I just
found you a couple weeks ago and I have
been dedicated on watching your uploads
ever since if you do give me a shout-out
would you please do me the favor of
checking out my band's channel our band
is called Distortion
and you can best find us by searching
distortion animosity it will be three of
us a lot of [ __ ] description here
myself now we're going through all this
myself the one on the bass guitar
well that is all I have to say hopefully
this isn't too long it's pretty long
thank you so much for the extremely
entertaining content you put up every
day I really look forward to watching
you guys but discharge but let's see
what I bought discharge looks like his
face is all over YouTube I'm sure you
wouldn't mind me stealing a profile pic
okay well everyone this is what butt
discharge looks like you can find it
after going to the bathroom yeah yeah or
after if you're like having anal sex or
someone's finger button and you got like
a little bit of wet stuff conversion to
your real name though because it's not
discharged know what those his parents
hated him they were drunk had a kid